chase young expected to go number two
overall the former Ohio State defensive
end but also high school basketball star
how good were you at basketball chase I
was pretty good um I definitely my world
not play with some good news DJ Harvey
today Ryan analyst Nate darling and I
was in Marketo votes votes was a
teammate of yours at DeMatha yes yeah
who was a better player in high school
now mark is definitely a best player
I've ever seen on play definitely are
very good to be a part of his journey
and his experience still to this day he
called me earlier I'm gonna call him
after I'm done with these interviews but
uh you know that's that's my bro or
looking do you know where you're going I
don't know do you care um you know it's
obviously it's not our choice um so I'm
I definitely care where I'm going
because this is a big moment in my life
but you know wherever I go you know I'm
gonna try to go in and you know just be
the best way I could be any downside to
playing closer to home oh no I feel like
you know it's pros and cons of playing
everywhere deathly cons of playing at
home you know big bros that I've talked
to around the league you know I've
already told me learn how to say no and
you know if you want to being if I were
to be selected by the Redskins you know
playing at home it's a lot of you know
obviously keep it really solid leeches
you know of people around that um you
know you know always going around and
you just gotta learn how to say no so
that's a one big thing that I've said
come on all the talks I've had with a
you know just my big brothers who are
too good do it yeah that's great advice
to give you because you're gonna have a
hard time saying no and even you know as
long as I've been doing this chase and I
still see younger player
they get caught in there they get
trapped and then people go hey I want to
be on the payroll because when you make
your money it's not just your money
you're gonna find out you've got a lot
more friends than you ever thought of I
feel like I'm prepared for good good you
should be
what's the party situation tonight yeah
so uh basically our house I'm up to ten
people in my house what we're going to
do that's I'm pretty different my mom
actually came up with it is we're going
to have a projector on the side of the
house and basically that's gonna give it
a chance for my friends and more of my
family I'm the conductor and actually
watching outside of my house so when I
do get drafted um then I can just come
outside and I can create everybody from
outside so you know basically just
trying to make this day on this safe and
it's claimed as possible you know so we
need to make this the best day possible
what's on the menu so Chipotle is
actually going to cater it so you know
we're gonna have a no bunch of
supposedly fair for well we change them
I don't want you to get in trouble with
the NFL if they if they know that you
know Chipotle and then like I don't want
you to I don't want the NFL to say hey
you know you can't have any advertising
there so just be careful yeah yeah I
don't want you to get in trouble
send some to the commissioners house
maybe that'll help
yeah I don't want you to get in trouble
your dad was a basketball player but
he's like six six nine or six ten in me
yeah he's pretty big are you gonna grow
like your six spot you were small in
high school then you were you
quarterback in high school when you
started out we're growing up so who did
you play quarterback like probably like
Donovan McNabb maybe you could play both
positions for the Redskins you could
play quarterback and now I'm just
kidding do you talk to Bosa
at all all the time what's he tell you
he takes me earlier I just told me on
you know congratulations and I'm gonna
call them you know before everything
happens but uh you know that's uh you
know he's taught me a lot to work my
career
um definitely helped me to be the player
that I am today so um you know uh you
know my big bro
you're gonna stay with the hair I'm
gonna keep the hair in my head
are y'all never cut my never never cut
my 15 years from now you'll still have
that that look how much still have my
dress will you trim it oh that's a trim
if it gets too long definitely probably
trim it mom's okay with it oh yeah oh
yeah she loves my hair
when's the last time you talked to Urban
Meyer Oh
about two weeks ago what are you saying
you know just basically a no
congratulate me and you know you know
just makes you talking about the whole
process I struggle with this chase
because I I said this to start my show
today what I rather have you who will be
a ten-time Pro Bowl player or would I
take a quarterback like to uh if he was
a two or three time Pro Bowl like I
don't understand why you're not the
number-one pick in the draft or people
aren't going up to try to trade for you
I are you the best player in the draft
but you know maybe the foul I heard the
Falcons might try to trade up to that
number two pick because they were
interested in you I don't understand
this why other teams wouldn't if that
edge rusher the quarterback and we can
throw in somebody else those are the
three or four most important positions
on the field so I'm a little dumbfounded
and and granted I'm an Ohio native so
maybe I'm a little biased there but I
think teams would be crazy if they're
not interested in and at least exploring
a trade for you have you heard any other
trade scenarios here oh I mean I've
heard a lot
can you tell me you're not hurt
obviously the Falcons um I've heard the
Dolphins might try to trade the New York
the Jaguars
so I've heard a few teams that they say
might try to trade it but you know
that's something that I try not to
really pay too much attention to you
know I feel like you know what's gonna
happen this going to happen but how many
teams have you spoken to I know what the
combine I know I had five interviews in
a after that I talked to Detroit in
Washington
no okay that makes yeah makes sense I
know you're joining us on behalf of Old
Spice our United Way all right should
say United Way in Old Spice but if you
want to give the sales picture of what
you're doing yeah so basically um I
decided a partner um with Old Spice and
you know giving it back is something
that's big and that's a some that's a
part of me and basically what Old Spice
is doing and a couple of these basically
all work is rondalee every 32 teams is a
partner that were always fighting three
hundred three hundred and twenty
thousand dollars um with 202 United Way
to support just under privileged guys
and families and you know I feel like
that's something I take pride in doing
so you know that's why I'm part of our
spy good good stuff they're the three
day draft Athan with the virtual
fundraiser you can go to nfl.com slash
relief I'll leave you with this would
you rather be on the team with Dwayne
Haskins or be able to sack Dwayne
Haskins you didn't get to hit him in
practice no and you won't be able to do
that either this time if you're with the
Redskins but I figured you might want a
chance to pop him at least once chase
have fun tonight and good luck wherever
you go we appreciate your time thank you
thank you that's chase yeah former Ohio
State defensive end